awesome great so today our topic like
rachel mentioned is our studio and
sagemaker
and maybe i don't know if an apology is
the right phrase here but i have a
two-year-old son who's very into
spider-man right now
and uh and as a result i recently
re-watched into the spider-verse which
is one of my all-time favorite movies
and that's like heavily influenced the
direction that these slides have gone
today so hopefully that makes sense and
if not we can just focus on the content
unless on the style that they're
presented in but but i actually kind of
thought this fit because as we go
through this i consider both our studio
and sagemaker both kind of superheroes
in their own way in the data science
space and we're excited about this
collaboration the ways in which they can
complement and kind of work with one
another um and we'll we'll talk through
that today
uh again as registered my name is james
blair and i work as a solutions engineer
here at rstudio
uh just to give kind of an outline of
the plan for today uh first we're just
gonna talk briefly about our studio
workbench um i'm operating under the
assumption that many of us are probably
already familiar with our studio or our
studio workbench to some degree but for
those who may not be i will just run
through kind of a brief introduction of
what that tool is we'll also do the same
for sagemaker and then we'll talk about
our studio workbench and sagemaker
together and what that offers we'll look
at a little bit of a demonstration and
then provide some resources for you to
continue learning on your own and then
answer any questions that come up
through the course of the presentation
so our studio workbench is at its core
uh an r
centric development environment if
you've used the r studio open source
software either at the desktop level or
through our studio server
you're likely familiar with this
experience you have a development
environment that gives you lots of
tooling around working with our ways to
manage packages ways to manage your
environment edit files write code debug
all these tools are part of the rstudio
development environment
our studio workbench gives you this
environment accessible through a browser
it's typically something that
organizations will install host and
manage within their own infrastructure
within their own firewalls
we'll talk about how that model is a
little bit different with sagemaker
throughout the course of our
presentation today one of the things
that that rcdworkbench provides that you
don't find in the open source version is
you have the opportunity to support
multiple versions of r concurrently um
and there's some additional
functionality that's that's also
available related to security and
scalability in our studio workbench
itself
another kind of important component of
the rstudio development environment
especially as it relates to the topic
today is that there are tools there for
python interoperability so the ability
to
work in r and python kind of
simultaneously is something that's
available and that's not restrictive
just to our studio workbench that's just
a feature of really the r language but
there's some tooling inside of our
studio the development environment that
make it a little bit easier to work with
with python frameworks within
kind of within in our context and we'll
talk to why that's important here in a
moment
amazon sagemaker on the other hand is a
fully managed machine learning service
there are all a large and growing number
of services available through sagemaker
in fact at aws re invent just last week
they not some new functionality and some
new features that are being made
available on the platform so it's
continuing to grow continuing to evolve
it's one of the fastest growing kind of
aws products that amazon offers
and for good reason it's highly scalable
it provides access to a lot of native
machine learning algorithms
you have an integrated machine learning
environment for doing development and
testing and model deployment and things
like that and then it gives you a really
nice production ready way to deploy
machine learning models track those
models monitor them um kind of
everything within the scope of model
development and and machine learning
operations is available through the the
sagemaker platform
with this said it might be kind of easy
to look at these two different products
and these two different platforms and to
kind of pit them against one another
right
sagemaker provides a
machine learning kind of development
environment that's built on top of
jupiter lab that provides lots of really
nice functionality and our studio on the
other hand provides a development
environment heavily focused on the our
user um
thankfully instead of putting these two
things against one another instead
what's happened is we've combined the
two right we've said look what if what
if we have our studio
as an available
editor as an available tool through this
and this this effort has largely been
driven by the art community as as our
customer base has grown both
professionally as well as just the open
source users who use our studio products
every day uh there's been a growing
interest in having some sort of solution
offered through the sagemaker platform
uh and for a good reason right sagemaker
provides all these functionalities
around machine learning and tooling that
our users are likely very attracted to
but the r studio ide is the place where
our users feel most at home
and so we've worked closely with the
sagemaker team and we're happy to
announce that our studio is an editor
and an environment that is now natively
available through amazon sagemaker and
we'll take a look at what that looks
like in just a moment
and we're really excited about this
right we think this is we think this is
an awesome opportunity not only for us
but for
our users kind of everywhere within
within organizations throughout the
globe to use a tool in an environment
that they're comfortable and familiar
with with
the enhancements provided by the
sagemaker platform
[Music]
uh so a little bit of a summary of what
this is right it's a managed r studio
solution which means that
running r studio workbench on stage
maker means that as an organization or
as an individual you do not need to set
up install maintain our studio yourself
instead that's handled on the sagemaker
site it's simply something that you
choose to opt into when you set up your
sagemaker domain um it uses and
if you have an existing rstudio
workbench license um you can use that
license
and you can carry that over into
sagemaker um it gives you access to
scalable amazon resources
uh easy access to additional stage maker
features and capabilities like some of
the machine learning abilities and model
deployment and management and other
things that are that are part of what
sagemaker offers to users
and you have flexible compute resources
for the different workloads that you
might be involved in and engaged in and
we'll take a look at some of these
things in an example here in a moment
so here's here's a just kind of quick
little video and we'll actually look at
this in real time in just a moment just
to give you an idea of what this looks
like in sagemaker on on aws
you go and
[Music]
open up the the launch app drop-down
click on our studio if it's been
configured for your domain open up
you'll you'll have the our studio
workbench landing page
and from there you can start a new
rstudio session it's really you know
like
as simple as that is the the powerful
thing is that it's that easy to get in
to get working inside of our studio
again fully managed hosted maintained by
by sagemaker
and then just a
just kind of a word that i think helps
highlight the significance of this for
us but also hopefully the significance
of this for the r community in general
and this is a quote from therefore the
president of our studio
and he said our studio is excited to
collaborate with the amazon sagemaker
team on this release as they make it
easier for organizations to move their
open source data science workloads to
the cloud we are committed to helping
our joint customers use our commercial
offerings to bring their production
workloads to amazon sagemaker and to
further collaborations with the amazon
sagemaker team
and i'll kind of touch on that last
component here which which for me is is
kind of a personally exciting aspect of
this whole thing and that is that we're
not done right we're excited about what
we've started here we're excited about
what's available today but we're also
excited as we look towards the future
and what we anticipate being made
available in the near future and we'll
we'll discuss some of what that will
look like here towards the end of our
conversation today
[Music]
so with with all this said and done
let's go ahead and and jump in and let's
look at a demo let's let's investigate
what we can do what's available to us in
this integration so i'm going to go
ahead and switch over here let me see if
i can move
zoom controls out of the way
so i'm going to open up here's my
sagemaker domain on aws i can see my
user here in inside of sagemaker and
then over here i can go to launch app
and i'll see that i have three different
options here studio which is the native
sagemaker interface
rstudio which is what we've been talking
about here today and then canvas is the
new tool that was just announced last
week that brings some sort of some some
kind of no code functionality into into
sagemaker if we start with the
traditional experience just to give you
an idea if you've never been exposed to
sagemaker before and we open up
sagemaker studio
this is the kind of traditional
interface through which developers will
interact with with sagebaker like i
mentioned previously it's built and
heavily influenced by jupiter lab but
it's also heavily modified to provide
lots of integration with the sagemaker
platform and the tooling that that
platform
provides so here we can see i have
different tiles that i can scroll
through i have different projects that i
can start i have different kind of
work work streams that i can work on or
different styles of projects that i can
work on from within this environment now
this has been an environment that's been
offered by sagemaker for for quite a
while and our users may have have
experienced this environment themselves
there's there's been support for r the
language inside of sagemaker for a while
and typically that interaction happens
through through jupyter notebooks
now if we come back to our sagemaker
landing page and we go ahead and click
on our studio
let's open this in a new tab here
now we have and we get dropped directly
into
this environment that if you've used our
studio workbench before is likely
familiar to you here we have our landing
page where we can select sessions that
we want to work on if we have currently
running sessions we can create new
sessions if we want to we can view
projects that we've that we've
previously opened over here on the
right-hand side and we have some
additional control over suspending or
quitting the sessions that are running
we're going to be looking at this
currently running session this sagemaker
webinar here in just a moment but before
we jump in there and look at some of the
content there i want to go through the
new session process just to kind of
showcase what's available here
we'll go ahead and open up new session
here we can give this session a name
example rstudio sagemaker session
that's too many characters we'll just
say example our studio sagemaker there
we go
and then here we can select the editor
the only option available is rstudio so
that's one thing to be aware of if you
are familiar with our studio workbench
um
you may be aware that it provides access
to multiple editors beyond just our
studio those editors include jupyter
notebooks jupyter lab vs code with the
sagemaker and rstudio integration the
only editor available through our studio
is the r studio editor the the our
studio development environment
the other option that we have here is is
cluster again the only option available
to us is sagemaker and this is just kind
of an interesting note a little bit of a
side note but i think it's worth noting
and that is the fact that
amazon is is one of the first groups
that's taken the the launcher which is a
component of of our studio workbench
that allows it to integrate with other
execution engines like kubernetes but
amazon's one of the first groups that's
taken that and created a custom backend
for it and that custom backend is this
sagemaker backend
that's only available through the
sagemaker integration but once i've
selected sagemaker as my cluster i can
then define um we'll first talk about
this image i can define the docker image
i want this
particular session to be run on as it
stands currently there's only one
default image available but that's
something that will change in the near
future
and then the instance type here is where
i will select the ec2 instance or the
amazon compute instance that i want this
particular session to run on and there's
a whole host of options and this is one
of the great kind of benefits of this
architecture because one
i don't have to i get like i mentioned
previously as an organization i don't
have to manage and maintain this right
this is something that's set up as part
of my stage maker domain sagemaker is is
the owner the maintainer of
of the rstudio workbench environment but
automatically out of the box if i if i
go this route i have a very flexible
kind of compute engine that i can lean
on because i can decide when i start a
new session what type of resources i
might need do i need
heavy compute do i need do i have a very
memory intensive process am i going to
be doing some really heavy model
training with very big data and i can
make an intelligent selection at this
point about what type of ec2 instance i
want this particular
this particular session to run on so
that i have the appropriate resources
available to me as i run this session
the the other thing that's worth noting
here is that as multiple users are
engaged with our studio through
sagemaker they're working kind of
independently in their own environments
so that if one user
does something in their environment for
example reads data in that consumes all
available memory or consumes all
available cpu
they don't impact or negatively impact
the other users because they're all kind
of in their independent environments
i'm going to go ahead and select the
default image here start the session
we'll see a new session starting up
right here now
because we're provisioning a separate
new environment when we come in and
start a session inside of sagemaker in
the way that we've just done it can
sometimes take a long time to to start
this initial session because it takes it
takes some time to provision the
environment
make the docker image available get that
image running in a container get
everything up and running so that we
have access to our studio session but
once that initial startup is complete
that session is available
and subsequent sessions will start much
more quickly
and here we see this session didn't take
too long to take it up and running
let's go ahead and come in here and just
see what we have available and again if
you've used let me zoom in a little bit
here
if i can
there we go
if you've used you know rstudio
previously whether at the desktop level
open source on the server rstudio
workbench
in in
in any case
this environment likely feels very
familiar to you i've got packages that i
can scroll through down here i can
navigate my file system here i can look
at help for different functions i can
navigate and explore my environment i've
got the console here where i can execute
our commands i have this document pulled
open where i can
you know i've got my editor where i can
open up our scripts our markdown
documents anything that i want to to
work with in this context
um a couple of things just kind of
technically speaking that are worth
noting is one um amazon automatically so
sagemaker automatically mounts a home
directory into every session so you'll
see down here in the bottom right hand
corner when i look at files i have a
home directory available to me inside
this home direct this home directory is
persistent
so this is nice because this means that
if i am working on a project
and i let's say that i'm i start a
project in sagemaker
and i realize part of the way through
that i've under provisioned my
environment i didn't give myself enough
resources and and if i want to be able
to conclude my analysis i need to do it
on a in a more
heavily provisioned environment well i
can terminate my existing session i can
save my changes first of all terminate
my existing session start a new session
with a new bigger environment based on
what i've learned from from the previous
session and then once that environment
starts up i'll have access back to the
same files i was working on previously
uh within my home directory so these
these files follow you around this also
means by extension that if i
install an r package right if i'm in
here and i say install
packages
um let's do
yeah let's install the line package
then this package will install into my
home directory as a user package
and then it will be available to me
persistently from that point forward so
i don't need to reinstall packages every
time i start a new session in sagemaker
those packages are persistent and and
follow me into whatever session i happen
to be running on
and we can see those packages installed
here we can see the user library that
our packages i've installed to my own
home directory and then below that we
can see these system packages on the
sagemaker instance so that default
instance that we selected
contains a large number of kind of
commonly used data science packages so
you'll see in here we have let's scroll
down a little bit
we have the tidy verse in here
we have data table in here we have a
number of kind of common
data
manipulation and data modeling packages
that are made available here inside of
of
the sagemaker
the sagemaker image by default
okay so while this is
continuing to run down here let's go
ahead and look at a couple of other
things that we can do right so we're in
our studio and for our users this is an
environment that we're likely
comfortable in so i can if i want to
from when from in here i can start a new
shiny application if i wanted to i mean
this might take a minute while this in
package install
wraps up in fact let's come back
here
we're going to open our studio back up
and drop into our
if we can maybe we've frozen everything
up
okay once this pulls up we're going to
drop into our
webinar
environment that we have set up already
that is the running session that we
currently have for the the our studio
sagemaker webinar see if we can get this
to unfreeze maybe
of course live demos are always exciting
and things never go as planned
okay
maybe it'll come up for us if not we'll
switch to another environment and try it
in there
this is my this is my fault for waiting
off script that's what i get
oops
there we go okay
all right so let's come in we'll leave
that one running but let's come into
this environment this session that we
have running um again one of the
advantages is that other sessions kind
of tied up but we can drop into this
session and and go from here so um
again i'm in my our studio environment
let's just examine a couple of things
that we can do just to verify that
things kind of work and behave the way
that we would expect them to so if i
start if i create a new file i can
create a new shiny application we'll
call this shiny
shiny example
let's go ahead and create that
um i can run this here within sagemaker
i'll see in fact let's run it in
the
viewer pane here
okay
so i can run this here i can see the
behavior that i would expect which is i
have my rendered shiny application
running over here i can do what i would
expect to do which is interact with that
application if i wanted to i could then
publish this application to a place like
our studio connect or shiny apps io
obviously this application isn't of any
real consequence or significance but
this is evidence that if i wanted to and
and this is likely the case i can use
sagemaker to do things like fully
develop my internal shiny application
that i might then share on our internal
rstudio connect platform or some other
some other mechanism so shiny works as i
would expect it to um tools like plumber
also work if we come in here and say
let's start a new plumber api we'll call
this example plumber
we can see my plumber file running here
i can run this in fact let's do that in
the viewer pane again
there we go
so i can run this api in here
and again i have the behavior that i
would expect right
and and the nice thing about this and
the reason that i'm going through kind
of these simple examples is to highlight
that once you're into this environment
it works as you would expect i'm able to
install our packages i'm able to write
our code i'm able to interact with our
documents in the way that i would expect
whether those are source code files like
a shiny application or just a
script file that i'm working on or
something like a
our markdown document or
like plumber api or any number of other
things
so now that we've kind of verified some
of this basic functionality the i think
the natural next question and this was
kind of my next question once i once i
started getting into this and becoming
more familiar with sagemaker and that
was okay
i understand the significance in the
advantage from the administrative
standpoint i don't need to maintain
infrastructure i have a flexible
environment i've got scalable compute
resources i have a lot of convenience
on the administrative side when i allow
sagemaker to manage the environment for
me
but as an r user
what do i get do i just get rstudio it's
just running somewhere else because in
most cases i don't as the our user i
don't necessarily care about where our
studio is running i just want to make
sure that i have access to it but the
question in my mind was is there
something that i can now do that was
difficult to do before um and then the
answer to that is is yes there's a lot
of functionality within sagemaker that
becomes very easy and kind of natural to
work with once you're inside of this
environment
and so we're going to pull open an
example document here i'm not going to
spend
a ton of time and
just another note
all of the kind of code and everything
that we look at here is is available on
github and i'll share a link at the end
of the presentation that will take you
to the github repository the slides will
be there um any source code or examples
or anything that we look at will be
there as well so don't feel like you
need to frantically try to copy and
paste and follow along everything's
available and will be shared after the
fact
so i'm going to open up this is an in
our markdown notebook here
um and let me
just yeah okay
so
we're not going to walk through this
entire thing it's a fairly lengthy
document and i'll be honest this is
pulled from an example jupiter notebook
that amazon has provided so there's a
github repository that amazon has that
contains a whole host of sagemaker
resources examples getting started
guides
all kinds of just resources to become
familiar with some of the sagemaker
features
so this particular example here is
pulled directly from a jupiter notebook
that they provide that walks through how
to interact with sagemaker via via r
and so i want to highlight some of the
patterns and again i'm not going to walk
in depth through everything that's here
but i'm just going to highlight some of
the patterns and functionality that's
available and how we make use of it from
within this r studio environment that
happens to be running on sagemaker
now the first thing that we're going to
do let me just so we can start clean i'm
going to restart my session here
okay
now
um
i mentioned this previously as one of
the strengths of the r studio
development environment and that was the
fact that it works really well as kind
of an
er
not a front end but but it it provides
some tooling around python
interoperability right if i if i'm
working with python and r concurrently
within the same document i have some
functionality that can help me out with
that and that becomes beneficial because
one of the easiest ways to work with
some of the sagemaker tooling is through
the sagemaker python sdk
now i'm not i don't spend a lot of time
in python i'm much more comfortable in r
but fortunately the reticulate package
which allows me to bounce back and forth
between r and python can be used to
allow me access to this python sdk from
my from my r session and so that's what
we're going to do here at first we're
going to load in the reticulate package
we're going to bring in the tidy verse
as well so that we can use the tidy
verse for some things later on and then
i'm going to bring in this sagemaker
package that's available on the python
so here this import function comes from
reticulate this is loading that
sagemaker sdk into my our session as
this sagemaker object i'm going to go
ahead and run this
this will load up
i have already set up my python
environment the the default image for
our studio on sagemaker has reticulate
already available at the system at the
system library so everything should be
set up and configured so that you can
just kind of hit the ground running
and if we open up my environment here
we can see i've got this sagemaker
object that's actually the sagemaker
module from python so this sagemaker
object in my r session now gives me
access to all the tooling that's
available in that sagemaker python
module
now we're going to create um a couple of
different resources that we can use as
we go through this process of training
and tuning this model
so we're going to create this session
object and this bucket that identifies
an amazon s3 bucket that we're going to
use to store artifacts data and objects
that we create throughout the course of
this of this document
and then one of the really i think
convenient features of running
r studio directly inside of sagemaker is
the fact that i don't have to i'm
already permissioned right like
the the the role that i have when i open
up and start running sagemaker is the
role that i
assume whenever i execute any of these
sagemaker commands so i don't need to
re-authenticate myself to amazon
that's that permission is already scoped
and attached to me as like as i start
running here
so i can grab that roll right here by
running this get execution roll function
and notice as i'm interacting here right
i'm using this sagemaker module that we
see here
and this sagemaker module
is a python module that i've loaded into
my r session and so i access the methods
and different objects attach that module
with this dollar sign just as if i was
manipulating you know a list or other
object here inside of r
so here i'm running these different
functions or these different methods off
of sagemaker to to get this
functionality
okay so what we're going to do is and
again a lot of this comes directly from
this jupyter notebook but we're going to
pull down this abalone data set that
comes from the uci machine learning
repository um and we're gonna do a
little bit of manipulation on that data
set not anything super crazy we're gonna
download it um we'll notice that the if
we scroll over the sex column here is a
character column but it really should be
factors because we only have three
different levels here so we'll go ahead
and change that to be a factor
we can look at a summary of what this
data set now looks like
and we see that in height we have some
that have zero height
and we want to take a look at what those
are so we can go ahead and use ggplot to
investigate those we see a couple of
outliers here and then we have some
infants over here and we've added some
jitter to this just so that we can gain
more visibility into the data but we can
see that we have a couple of
observations over here that are infants
that are
that have
zero height reported so we're gonna go
ahead and remove
any observations where the height value
is zero
and now we're gonna go through and we're
going to prepare this data set for
training so we're gonna come in here and
we're going to
create these kind of one hot encoding
columns for
the the sex column
and then remove the the sex column
itself here
the other thing that we're going to do
is we're going to move rings which is
the target of our machine learning model
that we're going to build we're going to
move that into the first column of our
data set um sagemaker expects the first
column to be the target value when you
define models and so in order to comply
with that we're going to move rings over
here to the front
okay now we're going to split up our
data so that we can get training on this
um we're going to go ahead and
sample 70 of our data for training and
then the remaining 30 we're going to
split in half and have half for testing
and half for validation and we're doing
that here and again i'm not going to
step through everything the other the
other thing to highlight a couple of
things to highlight as we kind of round
this example out is one like this is not
intended to be an example of totally
great and and perfect machine learning
practices rather the intention here is
to kind of highlight how to use some of
the sagemaker features and functionality
from within our studio
and then the other thing to note is that
i am by no means a sagemaker expert so
somebody like i i
becoming more and more familiar as we go
and thankfully we have some folks from
amazon on the line today as as we get
questions towards the end that might be
able to help and provide some guidance
there um but just worth noting that that
um you know i'm i by no means consider
myself a sagemaker expert
okay so we're gonna go ahead and trim
down our data set to be
only
500 rows
um
the reason for this is because we want
to do some stuff towards the end where
we're going to submit
predictions to there we're going to
submit data for prediction to an
endpoint that we deploy
and we have to have the the maximum
payload we can submit is 500 rows so
we're going to go ahead and trim down
our test set to be 500 rows here
and then we're going to write this data
out as csv files to our local directory
now the reason we write these data this
data out as csv files is so that we can
upload it to s3 and that's what we're
going to do here we're going to create
these different files in s3 that
represent our training validation and
test data
okay
and then we're going to define these
input types so that when we
train our model sagemaker knows what
data it's dealing with so we're going to
create these
train input and validation input types
that just identify where the data is
living and what type of data it is
okay now we're going to go ahead and
start getting ready to train our xg
boost model so sagemaker has ready-made
containers for training certain types of
models actually boosting is is one of
those model types so here we can go
ahead and retrieve this model or this
container definition and if we look at
this and again this is all using that
sagemaker sdk that we've loaded into our
session
here we can see
here's where the the container is living
and we can reference that as we go
through our training process
now we're going to define our estimator
again i'm not going to go through
everything that's that's available here
um all this content will be available
but we're going to go ahead and define
the estimator that we want to use by
providing it with the container that we
want to train with the
instance type that we want to do our
training on
and
where the output should go from that
model and things of that nature
[Music]
now once we've defined what our
estimator is we can go through and
define hyper parameters that we want to
explore and how we plan on tuning those
hyper parameters again i'm not going to
walk through everything that's in that's
involved here but the idea is again i'm
making use of this sagemaker module
that's available to me in my r session
through this sagemaker object
we're also identifying our validation
metric here
now once this is all said and done we
can build the tuner that we're going to
use to
tune our our model we can give this job
a name define our input data so here's
the the path in s3 where that input data
is stored here's the path in s3 where
the validation of data is stored
and then finally we can use this fit
method of this tuner object that we
created to actually fit this tuner which
will go through and explore this
hyperparameter space that we've that
we've defined and identify the best
fitting model
now this job has now kicked off and the
thing that's significant to understand
is we've defined this training job
entirely to be run and managed by
sagemaker right so again we're using our
we're using our studio but we've used
these tools to orchestrate this training
job that is now being executed by
sagemaker itself and if we scroll back
up just a little bit to see where we
define our estimator we can see that
we've defined an instance type that
we're going to run this training job on
and we've defined some other attributes
so that sagebaker knows when we fit this
this tuner and we and we
when we
train this model it goes out and
provisions the necessary resources grabs
the appropriate container that has all
the available unnecessary dependencies
to run this to train this
xgb model and then runs through that
training job in a totally separate
environment
that's why when we ran this if we come
back down to where we're fitting our
tuner here
scroll down there we go if we when we
look at how we ran this
we can see that our r session isn't tied
up right we can still i can still
do things here in the console oops
all right i have a i still haven't a
listening r session because my r session
isn't being used to do the model
training it's sage maker managed
resources that are handling the model
training at this point now i can query
that process to see how far along it is
using boto3 which is another python sdk
for
for amazon services
so again we'll follow the same pattern
that we use with sagemaker we'll load in
this boto3
module as an r object and then we can
query our sagemaker
tuning job by running a few commands
from this boto3 library so here we can
see i have four in progress models the
job status is currently in progress no
models have yet succeeded and no models
have yet failed and if i look back up
here just a little bit i can see
that i set this max parallel jobs
parameter when i set up my tuner to be
four so that's why we see four parallel
training jobs taking place and i have a
maximum jobs set to be 10. so once i've
gone through 10 different iterations
here
this particular tuning will be complete
and we'll be able to extract what the
best model was from that from that
process
go ahead and run this one more time and
see if we've completed any yet
we see that we still have four
in-progress models so i'll let that
continue running and just kind of talk
through what the rest of this would look
like once we've
run this model we can then grab what the
best training job was out of the status
of of the the tuning job that we've that
we've run
we can investigate what the metrics are
of that model
and we can also figure out where that
model is being stored inside of s3 so we
have lots of functionality around how we
manipulate the models that get created
from our tuning jobs and then at this
point we have two different options
right typically the point of building a
model isn't just to build the model
itself but to then do something with it
right to leverage that model in some way
to run new data through the model and
generate predictions on that new data
and sagemaker provides kind of two
frameworks for doing that one is batch
transformations which is i'm not
necessarily looking for real time
inference but rather i'm looking for a
way to run a batch of new data through
my model all at one time
and that's that's something that's
supported through the sagemaker sdk this
walks through an example of setting up
and i'm not going to walk through right
now but this walk to an example of how
to set up that batch transformation and
run a set of new test data through the
model
collect those results and then compare
them to the original observations so
that's one option
the other option here is we scroll down
a little bit
okay the other option um which is the
one that i'll focus on here for a moment
is deploying the model
sagemaker provides native tooling for
being able to take a model that's been
trained in sagemaker and deploy it
directly into
into sagemaker itself as an an endpoint
and then from that end point you can now
generate real-time predictions by
submitting either http request to the
endpoint through other tools like you
might create a shiny application that
queries that endpoint and and generates
real-time requests based on user input
you might have a front-end mobile
application that's built within your
organization that queries this model um
through this deployed endpoint that you
create um
there's like like i mentioned sagemaker
has native support for deploying these
endpoints for certain types of models
this xgb model that we've trained here
is one such example of those
and so here we can see we use this
deploy method on our tuner object to
deploy
this model into this environment
and then once that model's been deployed
we can define a serializer for it and we
can use this predict method on the model
itself to submit requests to that
endpoint generate predictions and bring
those predictions back into our existing
r session
now let me come back up and just see if
our tuning job has made any progress
here
and we can take a look at where we're at
okay so we have four succeeded models we
have four models that are currently in
progress being trained i'm not gonna
wait for that to conclude but we see
that we're making progress here and we
can continue to query that progress um
using this moto 3 library that we've
brought into our session
now i'm going to come back into let me
see if i can get back into it here
okay so here i'm in i'm in sagemaker
this is the the
sagemaker studio so the jupiter lab
interface and the one other thing that i
wanted to highlight is if i come down
here
i can see this i have the sagemaker
resources view that's available to me
here and i can come in and i can look at
this endpoint section and i can see
these are previously deployed endpoints
that i have have published in
preparation for our discussion today so
here i can see these are both
models trained on the same data just on
separate days but i can come in here and
click on one of these and i can open up
an entire view into what that model
looks like and here i can submit test
requests to the model i can view what
the you know what how this model's set
up what the end point for the model is
um
information about the runtime of the
model if i had specified that i wanted
to enable model tracking i could view
things like quality explainability bias
these types of metrics are supported in
sagemaker as long as i configure my
deployment to to allow for tracking and
metric collection which i i haven't done
in this case um but but it is something
that's available if that's something
that's of interest
now to to back up a little bit right if
we come back here for a second
what's you know what what's the big deal
what's the excitement about this well
there's kind of two things
one is is maybe the the
depending on your perspective might be
the less exciting of the of the of the
of the two things here but that is the
fact that you can as an r studio
customer you can bring existing rc to
workbench licenses
into sagemaker and use our studio
workbench within your sagemaker
environment now you have an entirely
managed hosted solution of rcdworkbench
that you don't need to worry about
maintaining installing updating or
anything like that but it remains
flexible and gives you lots of
resources at your disposal for doing
your day-to-day analysis inside of a
native r studio environment
the other thing that we've just looked
at is once you're in that environment as
an r user you gain access to a whole
collection of sagemaker tools from model
training and tuning to deployment
monitoring all those things are now
available to you directly from within
your sagemaker environment now today
that access is managed through
reticulate like we walked through in the
example just now so using the reticulate
package we can bring in the sagemaker
sdk and then we can use that to interact
with the sagemaker environment from
model training and tuning to deployment
and any other things that we might want
to interact with
um
now kind of as we look towards the
future and and what's coming up in this
space um one of the kind of immediate
term things to be addressed is that
there will soon be the ability to bring
custom images for our studio workbench
in in amazon sagemaker so if we come
back here just to remind us of what that
looks like
if we come back into our home screen
here
when we start a new session currently
there's only one image available to
select from
but that will change in the near future
and there will be the ability to bring
additional custom images into our studio
workbench you could define your own
images within your organization there
may be predefined other images that are
available that could contain different
libraries different versions of r
that would support the use case that
you're after
the other thing that we're really
excited about and actively working on
bringing to the table is our studio
connect managed by sagemaker in the same
way that we see our studio workbench
managed by sagemaker today now it is
possible today to use rstudio connect
and you know
install and managed within your own
environment in connection with
rcdworkbench installed and managed by
sagemaker and what that process would
look like is you would develop and do
your work inside of our studio workbench
in the sagemaker environment and when it
came time to publish what you were
working on you just published that to
connect uh and and connect might you
know in this case connect would be
something that you've installed and
managed somewhere else but down the road
we anticipate bringing our studio
connect to sagemaker as well in much in
the same way that we have our studio
workbench integrated there today
it's actually when you set up the the
r studio integration on sagemaker one of
the things that you have the ability to
do is to pre-define
your both r studio connect
url if you already have an r studio
connect environment you want to
automatically
configure that for publishing from
workbench you can do that when you set
up workbench on sagemaker and the other
thing is you can automatically define or
you can you can set up and define an
rsdo package manager url for users to
use when you go through the the setup
process
finally a few resources uh we put out a
blog post about this announcing this
integration a few weeks ago there's a
link to that here aws has put out a
number of different blog posts um
there are two of them are linked from
here this this news blog is kind of a
general blog about let me just open this
up kind of a general blog about what the
offering is and what's available today
and then this getting started post here
is kind of a more technical post that
walks through from the administrative
side
what do you need to do to set up
our studio on amazon sagemaker how does
it work what do you need you know how do
you get the license in into the right
place and and what do you do on your
sagemaker domain to configure this to
work
and then finally there's this there's
this github
link here let me open this up
so this github repository contains the
slides from today as well as the example
code that we walked through like i
mentioned that example code pulls from
this repository here that's a whole
collection of our examples provided by
the sagemaker team these are all in the
form of jupyter notebooks but they can
easily be kind of repurposed or
reimagined into standard r scripts or
our markdown documents whatever the case
is now that rstudio itself is available
within the sagemaker environment
and james would you be able to copy that
github link into the chat as well yeah i
can't i'm anticipating that question
let me grab that it's a great idea
perfect
all right
there we go
okay so there's the there's the link to
this
github repository in the chat so you can
see the links to the to the um
additional resources under the slides if
you don't if you open up the slides
directory in here
it contains a pdf output of all the
slides and that resources page has the
resources links that we just discussed
finally as much as i'd like to take
credit for the fun theme of these slides
i i pulled these from a website that
made these freely available and i'm
grateful for that and and some of the
comic book
graphics and things like that were also
provided by free pick
and as a final note um thank you
everyone for your time today um i know
there's probably lots of questions and
so we'll we'll take some time here at
the end to
address as many of those as we can or
give the folks from amazon a chance to
address those if there's some better
suited for them but i just want to say i
really appreciate the time we at our
studio are very excited about this uh
and i just want to reiterate uh what
threefood mentioned in this quote that
is that we're committed to continuing to
build out this integration we we're
really excited about the momentum we've
seen uh we're really excited about the
early adoption that we've seen um and
and personally just from my perspective
i'm really excited about the
capabilities that this introduces into
the r ecosystem and i'm excited to see
what
what things people are now able to do
with the solution that perhaps
previously were unavailable or more
difficult to do uh now that we have this
this sagemaker integration directly
available so with that i'll um i'll see
what questions we have i think there's
folks that have been watching this the
slido link so rachel i don't know what
happened
happy to happy to help with that and
thank you so much james that was awesome
and those slides are beautiful
um so i we do also have some people on
from the amazon sagemaker team as well
who you may have seen were helping
answer questions in slido too
so i just want to
take a second to have them introduce
themselves as well michael and
giorgios if if you want to jump on for a
second
hi uh my name is michael shea
um i'm an ai ml specialist solution
architect from aws uh thanks for having
having me uh for today's session
really looking forward to uh having
conversations on our student on stage
seasoning thank you
hello from me as well uh my name is
giorgio sinas i'm a machine learning
specialist solutions architect as well
as michael i'm based in london
and i'm really happy to be here today
and
hopefully i can answer questions that
the community has
awesome thank you and i'll start by
going through the slido questions and
the ones that are the most upvoted but
we want to make sure to answer
everything as well so i've talked with
lou on our team about writing a blog
post that goes through all the q a as
well
and but just to address this one james
the most upvoted question was do you
need a paid rstudio workbench license in
order to use our studio in sagemaker
yes
the the way that we've shown this
integration today it only works with a
paid our studio workbench license
and that can be just to elaborate on
that a little bit further that can be
either standard which is a license for
one server one activation or enterprise
which gives you unlimited server
activations um both of those models will
work with sagemaker if you if you do
standard then sagemaker becomes your one
installation of our studio if you have
enterprise you could be running our
studio in sagemaker as well as have your
own on-prem solution you know you can
you have lots of flexibility at that
point but but the answer that question
is yes it does require a license for our
studio workbench
thank you
and i see eduardo you asked a question
that a lot of people have upvoted as
well and i'd love to hear from the
community too if you want to read that
question eduardo if you're still on
and i can i'll i can read it now if you
want to add any more context please feel
free to jump in
but the question was how does sagemaker
help
ml solutions designed with r
into production
is there a specific ml package that sage
maker can deal with for example tidy
models or carrot
yeah i i can speak to that with my like
i said i'm not a sage maker expert so
i'm happy to to be corrected by the
folks on the on the amazon side as well
but from my understanding today
right the the the
most of the functionality when you enter
when you interact directly with with
sagemaker is going to come through that
sagemaker python sdk so like we used
reticulate we brought that module in and
then we used methods and functions from
that module to manipulate and train a
model and deploy the model and all those
types of things
now
one of the kind of underlying components
of that is the fact that all that that
whole process that model training tuning
deployment process is all actually
happening in python right the container
that we ran was was running xg boost and
interacting with that via python we were
managing it from the r side with
reticulate but most of the work was
being done on the python side
now there is support in sagemaker for
being able to define kind of your own
custom containers and images for model
training and deployment where you could
define ways to interact with our
processes but to my understanding today
there's not a lot of native art tooling
there yet now that's something i'd love
to see change and something that i'm
hopeful will change over time as this
partnership continues to grow and expand
that's i've had discussions with folks
about what some changes i'd like to see
for example and this is this is an
indication that this will happen but my
own personal
just you know utopian future would be
that there is an r native sdk for
sagemaker that allows our users to to
natively interact with stage maker
resources as well as support for things
like tidy models
and sagemaker now there's a lot of work
to be done to get there and again this
isn't a promise that that will ever come
to fruition but you know it's something
that i'd like to work towards and would
love to see happen
and today uh this is michael so i'd like
to add on what james has has provided
in sagemaker you can definitely bring in
your our containers so you can package
your tiny models garage
into your container and start training
and also hosting your models built
natively within her into sage maker and
and then you know
and doing all the ml ops clcd along with
sage maker using the sagemic sk
within your our environment so we do
have a couple of resources and artifacts
showing how to do so so happy to share
those information
awesome thank you michael
and james i know you addressed this
question
a bit towards the end but i think it'd
be good to address as well but um chica
asked is it a good solution for host is
this a good solution for hosting and
developing shiny applications
yeah so for developing absolutely right
it gives you a valid environment where
you can develop these shiny applications
and the nice thing is you can develop
these applications in a way that
natively reaches out to and interacts
with your aws resources so it becomes
really easy because you're already
operating inside of aws to read data in
from s3 and to interact with other aws
resources without needing to worry about
like credential management
now that's on the development side on
the like publication and hosting side
this story's a little bit different
today because
currently r studio connect which would
be kind of the preferred method of of
deploying and hosting shiny applications
isn't something that's offered through
sagemaker that's that's the next step
for us is is making that available and
it's something that's that's under
current conversation to have done
um and so we're hopeful that will be
available shortly um but in the meantime
what that means is you would develop
inside of our studio workbench on
sagemaker and then you would publish or
deploy that application to some other
location whether that's rstudio connect
you have separately installed and
managed somewhere else or shiny apps io
or some other solution um the challenge
with that is the fact that once you kind
of cross that boundary and you're no
longer operating inside of that kind of
sagemaker domain
now you have to start thinking about
like how do i you know if i'm
interacting with other aws services for
example like s3 now i need to make sure
that i have my credentials under control
and i know what i'm doing in terms of
like authenticating with the service um
when when r studio connect becomes
available through sagemaker i imagine
that that story will become a little bit
more clear because you'll be able to
publish directly from workbench on
stagemaker to connect on sagemaker and
you'll still have that same kind of nice
native authentication that's already
taken place
awesome thank you
um
rayon i see you asked a question around
advantages of using tidy models within
sagemaker would you want to jump on in
and add any context to that question too
i can hear him yes i can yeah thank you
very much um i think partly this
question was answered um
i was just asking if tidy models taken
advantage of sage maker
and whether it runs in a separate
environment but as uh james said
uh at the moment python is doing the
heavy heavy lifting
yeah that's that's correct i again i
would love to you know this is still
early stage for us we're
beyond excited about what we're seeing
and and you know what we see as we look
towards the future and we'll we'll
continue to work towards that future um
with with the sagemaker team i would
love to see you know like sagemaker
added as an engine on the tidy model
side again
whether that happens or not remains to
be seen but i can see ways in which that
could happen um but but again you're
entirely correct in the fact that today
if you're trying to use some of the
native tooling and technology what's
available is primarily on the python
side thankfully we do have a good entry
point in there via reticulate um but i'm
hoping that kind of that our aspect will
start to kind of build out over time
here as well
great thank you
maisie i see you asked a great a great
question as well
from the zoom chat
and i think you copied over to slido too
if you'd want to ask that one live
uh sure um
oh yeah um so when i before i saw the r
studio launch in this studio lab and
sagemaker i i started kind of building a
workflow with the r kernel in the
notebook instance and so i wanted to
just know like what would be the
difference between or what would yeah
what would be the difference between
using the r kernel in the notebook
instance versus like our studio in the
studio lab
yeah really good question
like functionality wise there's not
going to be much of a difference in
terms of like what you can or can't do
or what types of workflows are aren't
supported really what it comes down to i
think is just a preference right like if
i'm comfortable using the arc kernel in
the native kind of
jupiter style environment then then i
can do that and and i can interact with
my environment that way
what we found and one of the main
motivating factors behind this whole
integration has been that many our users
have come to sagemaker and said look we
we'd really love to have our studio
because it's home to us right we feel
comfortable we know what to do it just
it's it's we we have fewer barriers to
entry when we're using in our pseudo
type environment and so
it's really just kind of an
environmental preference right i i
myself am much more comfortable in our
studio than i am inside of jupiter so
any chance i have to work inside of in
our studio environment when using r um
is is something that i'm going to jump
at so in terms of functionality i don't
think you have really any significant
differences it's just a matter of
preference in terms of which environment
suits suits you better
got it thank you
thank you and next question was an
anonymous one that was is our studio
workbench fully on stage maker or is it
using sagemaker as a launcher back end
which would still require a front-end
workbench
oh man such a good question i meant to
talk to this point because it's a it's a
very nuanced question but it's a good
one so
when you set up your sagemaker domain to
support our studio one of the things
that you do is you identify a persistent
instance that will host our studio so so
you're right there does need to be some
persistent environment that runs that
then launches these sessions into into
sagemaker and allow sagemaker to manage
the resources behind those sessions so
there is that persistent environment um
i believe the default and it doesn't
need to be very big because there's not
any computation happening there that
environment gets automatically
provisioned for you when you set up this
inside your sagemaker domain and you can
decide what instance type you want i'm
trying to remember i think t3 medium
is kind of the default and i believe
that sagemaker gives that to you for
free like as part of the rstudio
offering on sagemaker that that host
environment that's just running
constantly to support the r studio front
end is is there and it's but it's it's
still maintained by sagemaker and i and
i don't believe it's it's something
that's charged for
yeah just quick comment on that uh james
you're right both on the instance uh
type it's d3 medium and it's also uh
free
perfect thank you for confirming
awesome
there's another question that was what
are the expectations for environment
management is it managed by aws or
studio me
will i have access to the same
environment two years from now to
maintain reproducibility
yeah so so there's
i think there's two sides to this
question
uh because environment can mean a couple
of things so one is like your local r
environment is is within your control so
if you want you know you can install
packages those will go into your home
directory that home directory is
persistent like we mentioned so
different sessions that start will have
the same access to the same files and
packages that you were working with
previously and what that means is that
you know their support for things is
automatically because of that fact is
automatically support for things like rm
so if you wanted to create a very
specific collection of packages for a
very specific project and have those
version to a very specific set of
versions that's totally supported um
through tools like rm um
you know in combination with with what
you're getting out of sagemaker so your
local environment totally within your
control and certainly you can set it up
so that you can come back to that
environment two years down the road and
you know reinstantiate it the way that
it was and and continue working from
where you left off the other side of
this is you know what about the
administrative environment you know the
the server the settings for for uh our
studio workbench things like that that's
something that falls under the sagemaker
control under sagemaker's control right
so when you say look i'm going to set up
and manage our studio workbench through
sagemaker part of what you're doing is
saying i'm going to let sagemaker handle
the rstudio administrative tasks for me
which can be a huge benefit because i
don't have to worry about that stuff
anymore and this particularly you know
i'm i'm really excited to see how this
helps
we work with a lot of organizations that
are very window-centric and all of our
software needs to be installed in linux
environments and that sometimes is a big
hurdle to overcome now the sun you can
say look i'm just going to let sagemaker
manage and host it for me and i don't
need to worry about all the linux stuff
behind the scenes as long as i can work
with aws to get the domain set up right
then i've got an environment i can use
um but the other thing that that means
is that i'm letting sagemaker handle
that for me so if there's questions or
concerns or things that i want adjusted
there or you know features that i want
enabled or whatever that becomes a
conversation to have with sagemaking
and then it looks like sorry just real
quick there was a clarification in the
chat
about uh it says the question about
environments was more to do with system
libraries rather than our packages so
the system libraries component typically
will come well two things
one is
you have currently today when you're in
your session writing on sagemaker you
have root access to that container so
when you go into the terminal tab of our
studio you have already assumed the root
role so you can modify that container as
you need so if there's a system
dependency that you're in the middle of
a project you're like oh no i needed
this thing you should be able to get in
add it to that container at that time
and and run with it from there now
that's not persistent though right so if
i if that session terminates and that
container goes away and i start a new
session i'm going to have to reinstall
that dependency at that point
i can do it but it's not persistent
the other side is this custom image
functionality that we anticipate coming
to sagemaker in the near future which
would allow you to identify at the
docker level as you did as you build out
these docker files what system
dependencies you need available in your
environment and that's how you you would
manage those persistently
awesome thanks james and
for anyone who asked the question feel
free to jump in to add more context to
and and meet yourself as well
and and i will say let's maybe take one
more i unfortunately i'm i'm
booked back to back so i've got to jump
off a minute but i'll worry about that
it's going to be a bad time of
monitoring i wouldn't
i would love to hang around and answer
all these questions and part of me
really wants to but it's irresponsible
so let's um let's do one more question
that i've got i gotta drop off
awesome so
one other question is
you put a lot of pressure on me to ask
the
like this yeah questions i'm just going
to go from the most upvoted
so it was this might be more for amazon
but will our studio be available in the
new amazon sagemaker studio lab
yeah so um yeah i think i can i can take
this question so
uh for now sagemaker studio lab is is
only supposed to work with um jupiter
lab um
but if we see that there is uh
no interest from the community we can
take that feedback back and then uh work
with
uh with you guys from the rcd site to
see if we can somehow find uh a good
solution that could help the whole
community
awesome thank you
um james i know you have to drop to
another meeting um to the amazon team do
you have a few more minutes or do you
have to to jump as well
myself i also have another meeting to go
to
um okay but uh yeah we will try to
answer some questions on the chat
uh on the uh i guess the slider will
remain open if i'm not saying yes the
slider will remain open
and what we can also do is take all the
questions from slido and answer those in
a blog post format as well so i'll share
that with the recording
once we have that available so that
recording will go up to the rstudio
youtube before tomorrow
um and then we'll work on the q a blog
post too
but i also just wanted to give
anyone else from the amazon side a
moment to introduce themselves as well
um i know a few people from the amazon
sales team were on as well
who may have had to drop but
if anyone's here feel free to meet
yourself and jump into
well thank you all so much for joining
there's so many great questions i really
appreciate it and we'll do our best to
make sure that we answer every single
one of them um
i'm happy to stick around for
just like general questions around
resources or meetups or anything that
you have but unfortunately i know james
and the aws team have to jump
but thank you all so much for joining
have a great rest of the day